this weekend I went to Oklahoma to catch
fish with my bare hands roll tape
[Music]
alright I'm here with Jackson and
skippered and they are the hosts of you
tell them well hillbilly handfishin tell
me the idea of the show well we pretty
much just take city slickers and offer
them to the gods for bait and tell the
people how hot it is
oh that's a hundred and probably one
hundred and eighteen right now hundred
eighteen right now in other words we're
all stupid we're gonna slip up over it
real easy nice and easy so we don't
spook anything and they're not even
gonna know we're there okay for an hour
so quiet you're not even gonna be able
to hear it so I'm gonna have to keep my
big trap shut then this is what you've
been trained for right let's go I
haven't been trained at all
this is what we're doing this is it get
right down in here all right
sidle up next to this brush use your
hands feeling from the bottom
this is business ridiculous everyone who
told me I was stupid for doing this is
exactly right imagine words Taylor's
right that and then stick your hand over
in front of his face and I know just
stop okay and at what point do I shrink
like a girl now that we're in murky
water together I feel like there's no
secrets between us
no there shouldn't be no you know what
Jack's not in all the years I've been in
TV right now is the first time I've ever
been peeing while on TV I don't mind at
all but there's a camera I can't help
but look at the camera
snakes camera snakes I can't decide
[Music]
oh you're back now love it
Ruth ticking there yeah yeah we stand
where everybody being client we'll give
him a little shot a little better shot
than all right it's not us it's all
these people my entourage
I respect you getting up but you know
life and hip hop bill where I have my
hand uh-huh I'm out
yes you've got to get your hand on his
mouth he's an easy keep coming just go
don't go no wait come into my class now
this is this is the second time I've
been peeing on top you've got to squeeze
hard and bring him through your
bellybutton sweetheart
sorry got him
[Applause]
the monster catfish it's your hands that
are so big that's making this fish look
small and II is that weird hands are so
big that's the 40% of fish this is a 40
pound fish I weigh 210 back Andy welcome
to the Brotherhood
thank you you have done I've done
something that Taylor Swift is going to
do next week right near
sit on your knees lean back Oh
spread your legs let it come to fling it
match the tape the bottom comes you mean
you mean trap it by my genitals yeah
yeah that's awesome like he's coming
he's coming
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm very modest konima
look what I did
[Applause]
nice job nice job
thank you